thank you so today's innovation master
series web
it's called forecasting innovation what
drives the future this is sort of a
brand-new module for the master series
and what's the first time we've kind of
introduced it to the community that's
been following along and the things
we're doing at Stanford with Design
Thinking so let me let me just make sure
it's a quick quick recap I guess that
everybody who's listening probably has
heard the term Design Thinking it's
really something that started here at
Stanford we started talking about it
maybe about seven or eight years ago but
in fact the design program at Stanford
goes all the way back to the late 50s
when a guy named John Arnold came from
MIT and joined with a young lecturer at
the time man named Bob McKim and they
were big thinkers and they created this
multidisciplinary program a long long
time ago before such things were popular
on campus but now we've got both our
design programs for the undergraduate
and graduate degrees and our Institute
we call the D school and that's where
we're sort of propagating and
researching and thinking about how to
teach everybody the techniques that
design uses to solve big problems so
this is David Kelley's quote David
recently published a book with his
brother Tom Kelly from IDEO on creative
confidence and he says the side thinking
is all about unlocking potential and
creating creative confidence in our
students and that includes the people
who come on campus for executive
education we have a very simple model
you know there's sort of a five-step
process we always believed in human
centered design you start with empathy
you start with the deep dive on the
human situation in any kind of a process
whether you're designing a product or a
service or an experience like the
experience of Disneyland we just start
with empathy which gives you the raw
materials you can use to redefine the
problem we spend a lot of time teaching
book in the master class in here on
campus students the ideas around brain
storming mind mapping morphological
analysis biomimicry dozens and dozens of
techniques to create more a rich pool of
more and better ideas because we believe
that if you're choosing from a large so
much
good ideas you choose better how men in
our process is a very prototype and test
and iterative kind of a methodology
because the kinds of problems that it
works on kind of required that kind of a
solution so you know we think of it in
really three ways
there's an old there's an old formula I
guess in business that problems finding
press plus plus problem solving equals a
strategic advantage and mostly in the
engineering and in business worlds you
think about problem solving and you know
what design thinking is a good method
for problem solving it works well on
these poorly bounded problems these
problems that are kind of open-ended and
have lots of sort of unknown
stakeholders when you start and the way
it works is it uses sort of a rapid set
of prototypes or instances in the world
to just ask new questions and kind of
collapse the boundary conditions the
prototype and test cycle allows for
rapid learning and improvement and it's
really prototypes in this way we define
it are not designed to be solutions so
much as ways of inquiring about the
problem but then we use you know many
many creativity techniques to make sure
that we have innovative outcomes but
probably where Design Thinking differs
the most from other methodologies is we
we really think of it as a new approach
to problem finding typically and I've
been a consultant for 15 or 20 years and
the valley here and when we work with
industry partners Stanford won one of
our sort of big ideas is that we're
typically working on the wrong problem
we're typically working on symptomatic
things rather than core things and it
really takes some time and some methods
we have for frame working to reframe
problems and we use you know ethnography
and observation and prototypes to sort
of reveal what the actual and latent
needs are the things below the level of
the the surface of the iceberg that you
can see and that gives us in total a
sort of a new perspective on value
creation because it's a very human
centered process and
it co-creates with all of the
stakeholders so you know that's that's
interesting and for a long time you know
we in our in a master class in classes
we do at Stanford you know we've been
focused on teaching this methodology for
problem solving rapid prototyping and
iteration and lots of creativity but but
of course the interesting thing is that
you may discover needs even important
latent needs things that are very
meaningful to people through this
process and through that framework up
some design principles that are very
powerful to solve the problem only to of
course discover that the problem changes
over time customers before smartphones
you know had a certain set of needs but
now that smartphones are you know in
twenty five or thirty percent of the
population the needs of smartphone users
now emerge to be really quite different
than they were before
and the expectations people have of your
solution change as they become more and
more familiar with the state of the art
and so we've been looking at how do you
understand how things change over time
and turning to the field of forecasting
luckily we have a fantastic class in
that here at Stanford called forecasting
for innovators and one of the
instructors is that class Cynthia is
here to sort of walk us through the
frameworks we use to add Ike and I think
a really important element to the notion
of design because it's not static it
changes over time and so I'm going to
turn it over to Cynthia to talk to you
about a it's a very broad framework and
we can't we don't have time to do all of
it but to talk to you a critical part of
that framework which is figuring out
what are the drivers that cause change
that would need to be understood in
order to forecast technology and
innovation well so Cynthia
thanks Bill yeah let me just add a
little bit more about why I believe that
innovators should think about the future
this way you know first of all when you
come to coming up with new ideas you
want to come up with strategic solutions
you don't want point solutions you don't
want to design in a vacuum and you know
everything is in fact connected both the
past and the future technology your
competition the business the politics of
the of the day and a lot of what we do
in design thinking helps us to to look
at these different elements but to move
them forward in the future is really a
you know way to think strategically
about this also you'll have the best
chance for success if you don't design
in a vacuum if you understand who's
coming along behind you and what the
future could possibly hold secondly you
want a sustainable solution when you're
coming up with new ideas you do want
your innovation to be around for a while
you know nobody wants to design a
product that will be obsolete tomorrow
and and certainly a lot of times we work
on designs and innovation that we want
to have a big impact and the things that
have a big impact in this world are
pretty complex problems you can't design
in isolation and the future can be quite
complicated we talked about a range of
possible outcomes not just a single
outcome when we do our forecasting class
here at Stanford we talk about possible
futures not these future we're not you
know teaching clairvoyance here what
we're teaching is ways to understand how
the future could possibly unfold and and
how you could play in a number of
different scenarios not trying to
second-guess the exact thing that was
going to happen
so let me just take a minute to kind of
give you a quick overview of our
forecasting process I'm not going to go
through this whole of the whole process
today but essentially start with an
initial question or your area of inquiry
or interest once you've got that defined
well you move on to context do you
understand the history and the issues
that are related to this field that
you're looking into moving on then to
drivers have changed what are the key
elements that will drive change in this
field of interest that you're playing in
once you've identified what the drivers
are we think about different outcomes
what possible futures could you know
could emerge and then once you've
defined what different futures could be
out there you can think about what your
options are why are you doing this
exercise in the first place why do you
care and how do you want to participate
in that future there are a number of
tools as well that we use throughout
this process the initial piece around
central at your central question is
about vision and I'll talk just a little
bit about I said what a central question
could could look like but this is the
the big-picture visioning thing that you
that you hear lots of entrepreneurs talk
about it get excited about the next
piece is really really different though
the context piece is about research
understanding the world around you
understanding the context of your
innovation takes takes research which is
frankly really really different than
than visioning the third piece around
drivers is around insight that's where a
lot of the creativity comes into play
where you are looking for what are the
key elements that you want to you want
to focus on once you've identified those
creating two different futures is about
structure we've got some structure and a
process that we use to think about the
range of outcomes
and then that last piece is is about
options and it's about action what kind
of action do you want to take do you
want to just watch and see how the
future unfolds do you want to place some
bets do you want to drive the future do
you want to change it what are you going
to do with this information once you've
created it so we're going to focus today
on a little bit on this middle piece on
the key elements driving change and
about insight and we're going to do that
primarily because we use a lot of the
design thinking tools that we use here
in the d.school and the department at
Stanford and a lot of these are tools
that some of you may be familiar with
and and others may not be but we'll
focus primarily on this drivers piece
today but first let me speak just very
briefly to the first two elements so
that when we talk through drivers still
make a little more sense so focusing on
a central question essentially this as I
mentioned this is the vision piece where
you broadly define the opportunity to
space your grand aspirational vision
this is your chance to get people on
board draw people and get people excited
about your topic to people to want to
help you a good essential question has
no easy answer it stimulates questions
and it stimulates thinking deep thinking
you do if it's an easy question then you
don't need this process it might
represent a hypothesis but the point is
not to guess today what the future will
hold but to use this as a way of
stimulating your creativity and
stimulating your research and
stimulating good dialogue and discussion
so we've got an example here that we
used in our Stanford class a couple of
years ago when will a human marry a
robot it's a pretty interesting question
and it took it's a good central question
because it really stimulates a lot of
thought when when I ask people that
question typically their responses whoa
yes Wow that if that could really happen
maybe it could happen Wow it depends
what would have to happen for a human to
marry a robot and that's exactly what
you want
in your in your in your focal question
or your central question you want to get
people thinking and excited about the
topic the next person is context and as
I mentioned this is about research
research research and we do love
research in products design and design
thinking and that's a lot about problem
solving today we do need finding
techniques to understand users we do
ethnographic research to underline to
understand underlying issues and really
understand deeply what is going on for
people today what are problems that have
to be solved today what are the issues
that we want to address but when you're
designing for tomorrow it's important to
to do additional kinds of research and
particularly those of us in in business
are familiar with market research and
you know the types of secondary research
that we often do a lot of and that can
be pretty useful here as well but you
also just want to understand the history
the evolution of the technology in the
space what have been the milestones
what's the rate of change in this space
are we at potentially critical mass on
the after curve of technology or not
what else is going on who else is
working on this issue or the technology
pieces alongside you and certainly
there's no reason to reinvent the wheel
you want to build off of history you
want to understand it you don't want to
reinvent it so let's focus more though
on dry on the drivers piece today we
talked a lot about three primary types
of driving forces in this space the
first is a constant right so things that
think that are predictable growth rates
things like the aging of the u.s.
population is growing at a pretty
constant rate it's predictable you can
understand it well and but that's not to
say that that's not important in fact
that's really critical when you're
trying to understand
going on in healthcare today you need to
understand the growth rate of the aging
population in the US some people would
say that Moore's law is not constant
other people might might argue that
we're coming to the end of that but
those are our critical critical
underlying factors that you need to
understand about your space the second
piece is this is the second type is
cycles anything that's cyclical that
changing of the seasons and the weather
patterns at least for the start the past
several hundred years that may be
changing in the near future political
elections have been on a cycle all sorts
of things come in cyclical patterns that
you need to keep an eye out on and then
last is novelty these are the things
that that may come as a surprise they
may be easy to forecast but they're
they're kind of unique elements in
history the recent US government
shutdown for example is hopefully a
novelty discovery of a new drug you know
major technology advances these are all
novelties and so these are three
different ways of thinking about
different types of driving forces excuse
me
the other way we think about driving
forces is that they tend to fall into
one of three major categories and these
would be culture applications and
technology what we mean let me start
with technology because that is the ones
that most people think of and focus on
and particularly here in the School of
Engineering people think about
technology as driving the future this is
the science these are the tools that we
use these are the underlying components
of the products that that we create and
are critical critical components of
creating major innovations oftentimes
however technology folks tend to
overlook the impact most positive or
negative of the applications and the
culture so by application so what I mean
is usefulness functionality how do we
use the technologies that we're creating
and why do we care you know battery
technology is a great but unless we're
actually applying it to something unless
you're actually applying it to something
it's it's just not that useful to to
consumers so applications are the second
group of driving forces how are things
used for people and then the third piece
is culture
what about society's influence what are
trends going on those product adoption
trends changing changing societal trends
politics regulatory factors what is
going on in the world around us that
could either advance or impede major
major innovations so let me talk through
the robotics example that I just
mentioned so in the class that we that
we taught we use this question when will
a human marry a robot and when we
thought about the technology side we
asked you know what scientific
breakthroughs or technological advances
need to happen to make a machine
functional as a human partner so the
technology side was was a lot about
battery power and mobility and
artificial intelligence that the
technology pieces that we think of that
to go into into robotics the next piece
with the applications
what intermediary products or services
or functions need to come together to
create a desirable life partner
so what were the different different
functions that that you would expect I
think and maybe this is a little callous
but what functions would you look for in
a mate yes and what functions what
robotic functions might need to happen
kind of in between where we are now to
get to those functions that you would
want that are desirable in your mate and
then thirdly from the culture
perspective what society what social
political legal and other issues emerged
as we think about people up marrying
machines I mean think about that if
you're if you were actually going to
marry a machine what what changes would
we need to see in the culture in the
world around us to make that acceptable
and legal and we found that those that
that opened up a whole set of
interesting questions
so as we focused on each of these areas
we thought about using design thinking
tools to help us deepen deepen our
knowledge in these areas now remember we
did a whole bunch of research here as
well to understand the history and the
technology and evolution of the robotics
industry so we weren't just coming in at
this in in cult if if you come in with
some knowledge and some understanding of
the space it will give you a lot more a
lot more to work with so one one design
concept that we use a lot in this class
actually is idea Maps some of you may be
familiar with idea Maxim's you may even
use these for that even knowing that
knowing that there's a name for them but
essentially the concept is you put your
idea or your issue down on a large piece
of paper and frankly I favor using a
wall and a group of people for this
because it's it's it's stimulating and
insightful to see it a large scale and
to be working on it with a team so you
put your idea or your issue in the
center and just train of thought start
putting out categories or sub
or things that thinks that that relates
to this issue in the middle and then
other elements of interest and think
about how they're connected and build it
up this is not a tool that's necessarily
used for communication it's a tool
that's used for thinking get your
thoughts out and and and communicate
with your team and build off of your
ideas and you know this isn't a great
photo but it's a good example of one why
you wouldn't use it to communicate with
anyone outside of your team but two it's
a it is meant to just get your thoughts
out and on a piece of paper and build on
itself and build connections and and you
can start to see some patterns emerge as
to what are some of the key elements
that you think are emerging time and
time again which are the big pieces
which are the smaller pieces which ones
are connected so idea maps are a great
tool a great tool to use to stimulate
your thinking another tool that that we
talked a lot about in the d.school
is brainstorming again that's a tool
that people may be very familiar with
but we talk a lot about how
brainstorming takes practice and if you
set yourself up well and remember the
rules of brainstorming it can be really
a very very effective tool particularly
in a group just briefly the rules that
we is are around differing judgments so
you want to avoid criticism the dread of
criticism is the death of genius that
will there's no sure sure way of
silencing a group but other than telling
them how bad they are second piece is
quantity Thomas Edison said you have a
great idea have a lot of them
Thomas Arduino Thomas Edison for a
couple of key inventions but in fact he
had thousands of patents thousands as
patents so he would know quality equals
crazy I love this quote one does not
discover new lands without first
think to lose sight of the shore for a
very long time really I like I like that
quite a lot you're not gonna discover
anything new if you just stay in a place
- you're familiar with you've got to
step out of the bounds of of where your
comfort zone is to find something new
and leapfrog ideas are like rabbits you
get a couple and learn to handle them
pretty soon you have a dozen so build
off of your team's ideas using things
like idea map are an ideal way to build
collective thinking around a topic and
collective ownership of a topic as well
oftentimes in brainstorming sessions
you'll see a lot of post-its up on the
wall again I'm a big fan of getting
stuff up on the wall you can see things
and and participate fully and I think
sometimes that we have to do school here
must keep 3m in business from the number
of posters that we use but it's there
they're a great way to make sure that
everybody's ideas are included and put
up as part of the process so once you've
developed and these are just a couple of
the tools that we use to be thinking
about what are the drivers of change and
one of the big issues in the space that
you're looking at and but once you once
you get your long list of drivers now
what so you can create lots and lots of
ideas but but what are you going to do
with them
so when trying to understand the future
and thinking about the range of outcomes
we talk a lot about understanding which
elements has the biggest impact and that
can mean a number of different things so
if something happens or something
doesn't happen what kind of an impact is
it going to have on that space going
forward and mostly the things that
you've brainstormed we'll all have some
sort of an impact but what are really
you know as you're going through the
list of things that you've generated
what are really the things that are
gonna gonna have the biggest biggest
change or the biggest impact whether
they happen or whether they don't happen
and then second which elements have the
greatest uncertainty and uncertainty can
mean a lot of different things and
certainly can mean you're not sure how
how this technology or regulation will
unfold there could be a lot of different
options for it it could be uncertainty
about timing it could be pretty certain
about what the impact could be but
you're not sure whether that's going to
happen sooner or later and and things
that are just difficult to predict
around uncertainty are also pretty
pretty critical so um let me go back
then to the robotics example and show
you how we you know how we could have
went through this the prioritization
process so here are some of the items
that came out of our brainstorming and
our idea mapping elements so as we
thought about technology some of the
elements that came up and this is
illustrative this is not complete but
some of the elements that came up for us
that we're going to drive technology are
power issues you know batteries and
storage the physical body what what is
this thing gonna look like it again has
different components is it going to be
mobile what about empathy
how can we build empathy into a machine
sensors sensors had a lot to do with
both how you know robots got around and
how they interacted with humans learning
artificial intelligence and learning
capabilities and language it was hard to
picture a mate without some type of
communication back and forth some of the
applications that we found were going to
be pretty important where things around
entertainment robotics are often used
for entertainment Zach of course came up
we teach a college class so that was the
first thing that came to mind with lots
of giggles but obviously a potential
application in a long term mate
a personal assistant was something that
people could foresee kind of in the near
future
household service people were thinking
about the Jetsons and the robots of the
Jetsons how else were robots can can
robot to be used in a household
situation and companionship not
necessarily something we always think
about in robots but certainly something
you'd want to think about in animate and
income what about you know relying upon
your spouse or partner for income and
then from the culture perspective we
talked a lot about the legality of
marriage how do you define illegal
marriage with a machine what about free
will what a machine have free will or
need free will to be able to commit to a
long term relationship
what about procreation marriage is often
this sources procreation what about just
relationships in general and trust came
up again this is a shorter list as all
the things that that came up for this
class but you know as you break these
down into
three categories you can see that
thinking about them separately and
thinking about them and these distinct
ways can really kind of elicit some deep
thinking about the different the
different elements particularly in a
group of Engineers like we teach the
technology stuff comes out very easily
the cultural stuff takes some more
digging in some more thoughts and and so
having the creativity tools heading with
design thinking tools around to help
stimulate that kind of thinking is is
very very valuable along with the you're
making the time and creating the time to
use these tools well otherwise you just
it would typically get a group of
engineers that kind of stuck on the
technology side maybe the applications
so as I said on the previous slide the
way to prioritize days is to think about
impact and uncertainty so after we came
up with this list we went through and
characterized each of these as to their
impact on the future and their
uncertainty the definition of legal
marriage for example has pretty high
impact as to how this future unfolds and
there's a lot of uncertainty as to what
that is really going to look like and so
we went through each of these and at
that point we turned to a two by two
matrix and we can spread them out and
start seeing how how these things start
to interplay and which ones are really
kind of bubbling to the top so the ones
that were characterized as you know low
low doesn't necessarily mean that
they're they're of low importance
because they're they're absolutely
critical that these things get get
developed but their end to be kind of on
a path you can see them evolving you can
see how they're likely to
to emerge sensors for example are you
know a hot topic here in Silicon Valley
and they're really really critical to
happen but you can see how they would
would emerge in a way that's going to be
useful in this space entertainment
robots are often used for entertainment
already personal assistant we think it's
probably kind of the most likely initial
you know personal use of robotics and
then people are really depending on
these to happen so if you are working in
this space that's a really interesting
place to work that's on the forefront of
the the basic technologies looking at
the high/low quadrant these are the
elements that have high impact but
potentially low uncertainty compared to
some of these others so and while we say
low uncertainty again it can mean a lot
of different things you know sex for
example
has a pretty high impact on the adoption
I would think of of robots as potential
mates and you know once we talked about
it we figured there's pretty low
uncertainty that that's going to happen
particularly among a bunch of college
student states that that would be
probably the one of the near-term
applications the on the bottom right the
high uncertainty low impact quadrant
these are certainly you know must solve
problems but we're not exactly sure how
they'll turn out and so you know these
are things that you want to keep an eye
on and as you're thinking about the
future they're not necessarily
predictable but we're pretty sure that
they'll happen and they'll get though
they'll evolve but then the top quadrant
on the right is the one that we're most
interested in as we think about this
future of this field so these are the
things that have the high impact and
high uncertainty empathy for example is
you know who knows how how and when
that's going to work out
hard to say you know that's gonna have
huge impact as to whether that happens
or not can we actually build robots that
that has empathy and some would say
absolutely and others might say not so
much but these are the elements up here
that are most likely to tip the future
one way or another and so these are the
ones we want to pay the most attention
to as we think about the range of
possible futures these are the key
factors I also think it's pretty
interesting and I've seen this happen
again and again that that you tend to
see more of the cultural factors up in
this top right than technology factors
and and that's often surprising for the
teams that we work with but but in
reality it is some of these cultural
factors that are going to drive or
impede adoption of your technology there
are the things that are going to support
or create a market for your technology
and they are not to be missed
they're the most important they are
often some of the most important
elements that you want to that you want
to pay attention to
so once we've defined these most
impactful and most uncertain elements we
would take them into some structured
thinking about different outcomes and
different possible futures as they said
we're not trying to predict the future
but if you can understand a range of
possible futures then you can decide how
you want to play do you want to place a
bet on a single future do you want to
participate in a technology that that
could possibly drive one future over
another do you want to participate from
a political or regulatory standpoint you
just want to keep keep an eye on the
changes do you want to make some
investments in the space but once you
can understand the possible range of
outcomes then you can start some some
strategic thinking about what do you
want to do about that how do you want to
participate and and where do you want to
play and so we'll talk a little bit
about some of the structure that we use
to be thinking about this in in the
section of the a CBT scpt excuse me
SCPD class
there's a few questions here but I
wanted to answer ask Cynthia a couple of
questions because I just find the whole
topic you know really really interesting
I've heard you and your your
co-instructor Paul Sappho say on this
issue of research you know if you want
to look forward 10 years you got to look
backward twice as far so talk a little
bit more about the importance of making
sure you're grounded in the history of
the technology and the social changes
when you're talking about forecasting
sure thanks yeah this is part of that
context piece and really understanding
the rate of change in the area that
you're interested in what's going on
you know most folks have are familiar
with you know the technology s-curve
where a lot a lot happens and a lot of
failure happens out in the world before
you reach a critical mass of technology
advances and that's where kind of
classic hockey-stick of change happens
where all of a sudden there is enough
activity there's enough learning in that
space to really build on on each other
and so part of it is understanding where
you are in that you know in on that ask
her are you at the beginning of
something are you in the middle of it
and understanding what else is going on
the other piece is it it you can more
easily spot trends you can look for the
constants and the cyclical elements and
you can understand with what novelties
have happened in your space that have
made things dramatically different and
you know you're going to miss that if
you don't look back a considerable a
considerable distance and you don't want
to be surprised if you can avoid it yeah
I think it's I think it's just an
important thing to note that this isn't
some kind of like to say crystal ball
you know just guessing about the future
if you grounded in what's happened in
the past there's often you know
historical patterns that repeat the
other question I want to ask is it seems
like the
surprise me that the drivers that end up
in the top right quadrant are often
cultural because you know technology's
changing sort of exponentially more as a
lot of doubling microprocessor speed
every 18 months and and other other
things that are happening technically
you know now we're being you know sort
of bombarded with the notion that
wearable computers are the next thing
we're all going to be walking around
with headsets on and and little screens
in front of our face so we're going to
have smartwatches or we're going to have
self-driving cars all of these
technologies are possible and they're
changing very rapidly but it seems like
humans and and culture and political
systems are way behind now I've noticed
Google making a huge investment in
lobbying Congress to get laws in place
you know for self-driving cars so they
seem to be employing some of your
strategy of looking at key drivers but
can you talk a little bit about you know
how technology seems to outpace the
human rate-of-change
sure I think the autonomous vehicles are
actually a really great example of you
know how how major innovations happen
across a across a large population you
know we talked several years ago in our
class about autonomous vehicles and the
technologies were really really critical
them in terms of you know sensing
technology and you know robotics and if
you look back at the history of that
that space there were different
different ways of approaching this
problem back in the fifties and sixties
people we're looking at embedding
you know tracking things in the roadway
as opposed to having smart cars that
could could see each other and respond
to each other so understanding the
history of this space is is pretty
important but when you think about
actual adoption of autonomous vehicles
you need to think about what you know
what are the things that are are going
to really either drive or impede
adoption laws insurance coverage what if
these things get in an accident who gets
blamed
you know who pays for that what are the
legal aspects of driving of sitting in a
car that you don't you know that that
has more control than you do what about
the freeways and the roadways do they
need to be redesigned somehow to
accommodate these types of vehicles what
about the social contract between people
will we be in a place where you can
argue you're willing to put your
children in a car and let that car drive
them off to school which is going to
change the whole neighborhood of parents
at their schools and and being you know
I don't know if any other parents have
noticed the only time sometimes you get
with your teenagers is in the car so is
that going to change the whole social
social interaction of families it really
everyone kind of take this down you know
down the road so to speak that questions
that are really going to either help
people get excited about this technology
and want to use it or be frightened by
it or not adopt it a really kind of
cultural it's not so much about about
technology we have some questions so
we'll try to get through a few these
that come in from the webinar audience
you can take them in any order you'd
like Cynthia if you just repeat the
question sure um so there's a question
about how macro and micro are the key
elements you'd consider in the driver's
stage and you know when you're looking
at at the future I'd say you do want to
focus on them the macro things unless
there's something micro that could have
a huge huge impact you might think of
for example you know what I just said
about you know people putting their
children in cars you don't think of that
necessarily as a macro trend how people
carpool but you know that could that
could potentially have a large impact as
to whether this is something that
families are willing to purchase and
families are a pretty big piece of that
market so you do kind of want to think
carefully about which ones are going to
have the most impact and which ones are
going to have
which ones has a most uncertainty that
one you know we don't know I don't know
how parents are gonna react to this
let's say it's another good question um
can breakthrough or disruptive
innovation really happen in a structured
context yeah actually I think it can I
think
breakthrough technology can can happen
in a structured context you know the
vision part of innovation you know
happens at the beginning of this
forecasting process and happens at the
beginning of an innovation process but
in order to actually create that
innovation make it happen not just talk
about it not just think about it you've
got to have the structure behind it to
you know to to make that happen
innovation isn't just about thinking
it's about actually creating something
real in the world and that that does
create us that does necessitate I think
a lot of structure yeah I just wanted
this one this I thought was interesting
it says in a corporate world often
market research drives the decisions
occurred convert innovation into a
product what if it's something so novel
that the market research may not bring
the required numbers for business cases
in fact this is exactly what Clayton
Christensen described as the innovators
dilemma you know you're the big gorilla
in a marketplace all the other market
opportunities seem too small to chase
until some crazy kids you know named
Sergey and Larry you know leave their
PhD program early you know and create a
monster competitor I think this is
exactly what we're talking about when we
talk about using this kind of nonlinear
process like design thinking and to be
forecasting the future you may need to
make them bat now because you've seen
future trends emerging that could
significantly impact your your business
plan your market share or whatever those
in those investments now may not pencil
out to be as large a market as the one
you currently serve but they're the
kinds of disruptive innovation
to come up from behind and eventually
you know cannibalize your market if I
were Microsoft I would even though
Google Docs is not you know generated a
significant amount of market share yet I
happen to notice that all of my students
use it and they are the next generation
of users to move into the workplace and
they don't ever use even the more
capable that much more functional and
much more feature-rich products of Word
PowerPoint you know and Excel primarily
because they work in a distributed
campus where they need to collaborate
and so I think that's a primary example
where our distributed workforce in the
future is going to be much more
collaboration based than individual you
know PC screen-based anyway we're gonna
have to turn it back to Ryan at this
point because we're out of time thank
you very much Cynthia for an interesting
piece of content on forecasting thank
you